ha the other day my friend told me that
he was watching my blogs and he said my
material isn't really white America
friendly he told me wanting to switch it
up a little bit diversify making a
little more universal knock knock who's
there who a person
Oh what is going on YouTube I got a
question to ask you and asked there was
something that I haven't noticing a lot
lately what so many people stuff I'm
having everybody happy to like you hmm
you know I think I'm pretty well as
being that life is always about flowers
shooting at your butt crack and in case
you haven't noticed yet people are gonna
hate your [ __ ] guts whether you like
it or not that's life
you see if everybody has to like you you
know what out that means it means you
have to like everybody else to think
about it you hate people too don't you
and don't say you don't that's [ __ ]
impossible I'm not even kidding you
suddenly once told me that he didn't
like me because I was breathing wrong
you know what I said I turn to him and I
said you know what sir you are entitled
to your opinion then I turn around I set
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out with her if you
haven't noticed I'm hated on a regular
basis and most of the time is for [ __ ]
that's not even my fault
thanks for cancer [ __ ] what damn you
have any idea how many people have told
me to kill myself huh
[ __ ] you what is this middle finger
guessing this kill myself [ __ ] kill me
yo cells dose stupid ass looking face
medic yo face so [ __ ] up with like God
created you with his knuckles ah
dumb [ __ ] about me look at me when I
taught me with your lazy ass [ __ ] not
actually you ain't got a lazy eye that's
your eyeball run away from your ugly-ass
face but let me ask you this why are you
so caught up in what somebody else
thinks about you and I'm not talking
about your close peers and your family
I'm talking about random ass people
people who should not mean [ __ ] to you
there are so many other things for you
to worry about right don't you got like
bills to pay
homework to do if your kid go play with
your friends and touch yourself or
something that's not the same times you
are so worried and focus about what
everybody else thinks about you you
forget to worry about the person that
matters the most
yo hey you got to understand something
you live in a hateful ass society look
at me
you have to I love it hate people for
living a lot of you folks out there
think that the small popular life
venture in might now is everything and
it's not if people hate you now guess
what eventually those people will forget
about you because time will progress and
they will move on and so should you
kids junior High's small part of your
life
high school is a small party life and
college is even shorter than that you
see if you stick to being yourself and
then developing yourself as a person you
will eventually find like-minded people
for you to hang out with and those
people are the opinion that you should
worry about the most other than yourself
now if you ask me my life is good really
good
oh god the other day I looked at some of
my old post and I told myself by the
time I hit my mid-20s I was gonna have a
six-pack a ballin s car a dope ass job
and a finance woman and let me tell you
something do I got any of those I'm
still working on it
Oh what is going on YouTube yes I just
came back from Brandeis University in
Boston thank you guys for having me out
there um
Tammy and ku great me to you guys and uh
yeah it was super fun so I'll see you
guys know soon yes but as of course you
guys know on Friday we dropped two new
releases here's one of them right here
at the bottom side right there go for
broke and yes I got a couple of messages
yes the galaxy and the cruise they're
all gone now so once again these are all
limited so once they're out they're out
I apologize stop yelling at me stop
yelling at me
stuff my voice is a little bit deeper
right now because I record this a little
bit later because once again I just got
the plane so pretty [ __ ] tired yeah
huh but yes thank you guys for tuning in
and triple F will be back of course
on Wednesday I am getting closer and
closer to my goal because I really gotta
cut this [ __ ] hair I paint it so I'll
see you all again real soon what's up
what that look at this [ __ ] hair dude
see this right here holds me back so
baby you want my number kill myself okay
I'll do it